[Musik]
ach wäre das schön jeden monat 1000 euro
auf konto ohne einen finger dafür krumm
zu machen
der staat werde nicht zusammenbrechen
und viele menschen würden etwas
sinnvolles tun denn niemand will es sich
arbeit los sein
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen ist
das spinnerei oder ein zukunftsmodell
für zeiten in dem die digitalisierung
alle job trifft finnland probiert das
schon aus und auch die neue jamaika
koalition in schleswig-holstein plant
einen modellversuch
die schweizer dagegen haben in einem
referendum abgelehnt
ja 1000 euro für jeden sinnvoll ist das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen darüber
reden wir gleich in dieser runde
herzlich willkommen und das sind meine
gäste hier gibt es heute ein klares pro
und contra für das grundeinkommen ist
daniel häni er ist unternehmer aus der
schweiz hat die initiative für ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
mitbegründet und ein manifest manifest
über das grundeinkommen geschrieben und
ich begrüße professor michael opielka er
beschäftigt sich seit 1984 mit dem thema
ist leiter des instituts für soziale
ökologie in siegburg und professor für
sozialpolitik an der ernst abbe
hochschule in jena und auf der
gegenseite gegen das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen argumentieren heutige
hermann wirtschaftsredakteuren der taz
und ausgebildete bankkauffrau und
professor anke hatte wissenschaftliche
direktorin des wirtschafts und
sozialwissenschaftlichen instituts der
gewerkschaftsnahen hans böckler stiftung
herzlich willkommen herr opielka fangen
wir mal mit ihnen an
wie kann das denn eigentlich gehen dass
man sagt jeden monat bekommt jeder 1000
euro wie kann das funktionieren
wir haben ein sozialstaat der heute ist
eine menge verteilt er verteidigt
wesentlichen zwei dinge ist entweder
geld oder dienste und idee mit dem
grundeinkommen ist im bereich der
geldtransfers zu verändern
die transferleistung heißt es wird etwas
umverteilt die eigenen zahlen beiträge
steuern
die anderen kommen etwas die frage ist
habe heute schon wie ein kindergeld wir
haben betreuungsgeld wir haben glauben
werden elterngeld wir haben
arbeitslosengeld krankengeld eine menge
zahlungen türkischen stattfinden und die
frage die aber heute im wesentlichen
orientiert sind am arbeitsverhältnis und
der größte block grundeinkommen ist
ohnehin
meine freundin der schweiz uneins sind
die renten wenn wir heute über
grundeinkommen reden müssen wir immer
renten reden weil wenn wir können
unmöglich ein grundeinkommen im
lebenszyklus haben aber keins im alter
als es müssten auch eine grundrente
geben um diesem gesamtpaket so zu sagen
sie halt ist ein grund hat seit ihrer
ankunft sehr hohen für möglich ein
einziges mal weniger als eine art sender
ab der geburt ja also möglicherweise das
ist sehr praktisch formuliert weil
khammas sprach davon der grundrente nahm
ich die idee dass man sozusagen diesen
anteil am volksvermögen auf jeden zu
verteilen habe also grund rendite aber
die frage ist ist die zeit zu zeit 1000
möchten versagen mit hier keine falschen
diskussion aufkommen wenn wir heute über
1000 oder 900 oder in der größenordnung
reden dann meinen wir normalerweise
lebenshaltungskosten und die wohnkosten
und gerade im unteren eigentum im
segment sind die wohnkosten teilweise 30
bis 40 prozent in großstädten noch mehr
und das muss man auseinanderhalten also
diese zahlt man genauer hinschauen
bieten meinte organisieren aufgekommen
der tarifeinheit immer warum es sinnvoll
wir haben der schweiz darüber abgestimmt
haben aber 47 prozent dagegen bestimmt
sie haben es mit ihnen zu ihr handy was
ist denn ihr stärkstes argument gerade
in der schweiz erleben die leute doch
irgendwie sehr gut da gibt es viele
arbeitsplätze reicht nicht wenn man der
arbeitet warum muss man den anderen
grund geld geben damit die schweiz ist
ja dass man aktiv der schweiz in
deutschland ist vorgeschrieben ist aus
der selbstbestimmung und das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen wieder an
das anknüpfen und die die demokratie wie
sie in der schweiz am morgen abstimmen
können worauf wurde einzelnen und die
einzelnen souverän ist bedingungslose
grundeinkommen würde das auch beziehen
und ermöglichen
bezogen auf die arbeit also die frage
was man tut und was man nicht tut könnte
jeder und jede selber besser und zu
werden entscheiden
das ist der punkt als 1000 euro das war
ein äquivalent in der schweiz sie hatten
2300 franken kann man ja auch nicht
wirklich gut leben bei ihnen oder ja die
höhere die muss einfach so sein dass man
menschenwürdig leben kann dass man zu
unverantwortlich in sachen
sagen kann vielleicht brauchen wir im
moment noch gar keine zeit in
deutschland ist die diskussion noch
nicht so weit würde sagen dass man das
merkt dass man ein einkommen sorgt die
gesellschaft einzieht so dass jeder
mensch selbst verantwortliche leben kann
das ist die idee des kunden kommt es ist
übrigens auch nicht mehr geld gezeigte
am anfang gesagt hat das ist ein irrtum
den menschen ein grundeinkommen sei
endlich mehr geld nein es ist meine
freiheit also wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel 3000 euro verdient in
deutschland das grundeinkommen wäre 1000
hat man da nicht 4000 immer noch zwei
fragen auf
es ist das nicht mehr geld und mehr
freiheit mehr frankfurt vor hatte das
müsste eigentlich jana
gewerkschaftsnahen institution doch
eigentlich gefallen hat man da jetzt
noch einen total gerecht wenn alle
erstmal für das gleiche haben und es ist
klar davon kann man erstmal leben warum
sind sie trotzdem dagegen um das
grundeinkommen ist ja keine kleine
reform mit dem grundeinkommen wird das
komplette steuer und sozialabgaben
system praktisch radikal transformiert
auch der der sozialstaat uhr wer jetzt
ist wird er nicht mehr da sein und aus
meiner sicht gibt in der gesellschaft
viele probleme es gibt auch vieles was
wir tun müssen das grundeinkommen löst
aus meiner sicht keines dieser probleme
und wenn ich schon eine große reform
machen würde
wo ich auch viel geld in die hand nehmen
würde dann würde ich es einfach anders
investieren wollen ich wollte in die
schulen investieren ich würde die pflege
investieren ich würde in krankenhäuser
investieren also in alle diese bereiche
wo wir jetzt merken da gibt es einen
bedarf einen ganz konkreten sozialen
bedarf und was die freiheit angeht oder
was ist einkommen angeht sie wollen ja
alle ein gutes einkommen für alle wir
wollen auch wirklich gut leben können da
würde ich sagen dafür brauchen wir
einfach bessere löhne wir brauchen
höhere löhne für menschen im
niedriglohnsektor und müssen die so
anständig bezahlen
das ist kommt einkommen gar nicht mehr
notwendig wie sozial gerecht wäre dann
zum grundeinkommen frau hammer wenn man
es gibt es immer noch viel kritik an
hartz vier leute müssen einen hohen
bürokratieaufwand wenn man jetzt
beantragt das wäre dann alles weg das
wäre doch dann eigentlich auch ja was
gerecht ist dann erstmal alle dasselbe
haben denselben sockel
damit man nicht nicht mister steht ich
bin absolut dafür hart 4
für diejenigen die tatsächlich
arbeitslos sind anzuheben recht das ist
im augenblick viel zu niedrig und ich
hätte auch kein problem damit dass
arbeitslose die keinen job finden dann
am ende 1000 euro bekommen
aber und das ist aus meiner sicht das
problem das grundeinkommen 1000 euro für
jeden auch für millionäre für einfach
jeden ist nicht finanzierbar und um das
mal einfach klar vor zu rechnen wo das
problem liegt angenommen er ist jede
jeder 1000 euro bekommen also auch das
baby jeder das heißt man stelle sich
jetzt vor
ja das war aber die mode anmoderation
mit europäischer mit 1000 euro pro
person
mit zunehmender gewalt positionen hinter
vertraut hat zum beispiel der jetzt
gerade nicht sitzt aber ein buch dazu
geschrieben hat forderte 1000 euro pro
person und ich würde sagen 1500 wir
sehen kein sport
jetzt würde ich gern wir ihn ja schon
hier gibt's zwei der gegenseite ein
die fans aber angenommen man bleibt
jetzt erstmal bei dem was sie in der
anmoderation gesagt haben und wo es auch
vertreter gibt die das fordern 1000 euro
pro person
dann sind es dazu einen vierköpfigen
haushalt sind das dann snackt 48.000
euro im jahr so um 48.000 netto im jahr
zu haben muss man im raum krieg in
deutschland ungefähr 80 bis 100 1000
euro brutto verdient so das sind aber
nur noch 5 bis drei prozent der
bevölkerung
und da sieht man dass wenn man konkret
wird und ich kann das auch in jede
andere richtung infor rechnen wenn es
konkret und sieht man einfach das geld
würde niemals reichen umgehen mit 1000
euro an l auszustatten
anders gesagt was möglich wäre real wäre
500 euro pro person maximal aber dann
ist man eigentlich schon wieder beim hc
sein und dann wäre eigentlich das was
frau hatte gesagt hat nämlich dass man
einfach zielgerichtet investiert viel
schlauer aber dann müssen wir das
bezahlen
ich glaube das sind ja
milchmädchenrechnung sulgen sie sind
jetzt die milch nicht
aber mein einkommen zu unseriöse
diskussion die zu jedem thema rechnung
kann man hier im fernsehen nicht
einstellen die parameter klar machen
will reden wenn wir über politische
programmatik reden über soziale
veränderungen sind immer über konkrete
elemente sprechen und nicht über
ergebnisse sind element ist zum beispiel
die frage wer bräuchte denn überhaupt
wer braucht denn überhaupt ein einkommen
weil er jetzt zur zeit kein
arbeitseinkommen vermögenseinkommen oder
kein hohes unterhalb einkommen hat von
seinen eltern passanten - angehörigen
haben es angesprochen sind hartz iv
empfängerinnen und das sind sehr
interessante frage warum da würde man
auch könnte man auch anfangen athleten
im alter und wie die frage stellen wie
gehen wir mit dem thema sanktionen um
und heutige bundesgerichts magazin
sozialgericht hat schon sukzessive hin
im bereich rechts entwickelt hin zu
einer großzügigen große rechtsansprüchen
auf existenz
wir haben wir haben wir haben mit siegen
kann man finanzieren aber nicht
finanzieren
sie finanzieren wollen was früher mal
gerade an sprit ist ja keinen
finanzierungsmodell 1000 euro für jeden
für kinder bedeuten dass netto das ist
ein gerede das volk wird kein ernster
knie eingesetzt wofür ein kommen sie
müssen ernsthaft schauen wer ist da
wurde wirklich einkommen beziehen da
kommen wir auf ganz als jahren gutachten
dazu gemacht damit auch gerechnet und
diese werte sind völlig anders
das kann ich im fernsehen kann ich keine
kann ich kein tabellen vorlegen okay
aber sie sagen dass es eine zeit von
mohammed und abhänge etwas was ihr
rechner sieht wir müssen ja nur und
einigen auf den grundsatz und dann sind
vielleicht sieht man ja auch dafür gab
schlussendlich also aber das muss man
wirklich verstehen der grundsatz des
kroner kommt ist es ist nicht mehr geld
das heißt wer hat dann alles schon ein
einkommen in deutschland ja alle haben
schon ein einkommen in deutschland
das könnten wir gar nicht in deutschland
leben und die idee des grundeinkommens
ist jetzt dass man den teil des
einkommens den man unbedingt braucht ist
es jetzt 500.000 700.000 euro den
teilnehmern unbedingt braucht
mit man auch lebensfähiges damit man
auch leistungsfähig ist dass wir das
gesetz auf das einsehen dass das
sinnvoll wäre wenn wir diesen teil den
bestehenden teil der einkommen auch
bedingungslos machen indem es über die
jusos rausfahren es ist also gar nicht
mehr geld und deshalb ist es
finanzierung es finanzierbar
das ist nur ein ablenkungsmanöver bahn
sollte 300 menschen drauf sein ihm nach
1000 euro
und dann wird dieses diese 1000 euro
gebildet
stellt euch vor ganz einfach wenn man
das finanzieren will braucht man eine
koffer und eine kasse gibt es immer zwei
richtungen nämlich wie kommt das geld in
die kasse und ihr geld das geld raus dem
gewinner kommen ist es einfach aufgeht
für alle gleichen gleichen höhe raus und
wie es rein kommt darüber können wir
eine regel erfinden politisch eine sehr
interessante frage
die gewerkschaften können sich dann
dafür engagieren dass das auch in
welcher weise wir glück mir das geld
einfach aber es ist immer gleich viel
geld
es ist wie eine bedingungslos wäscherei
sie haben dann nachher sauberen händen
auf einkommen ohne bedingungen
aber sie haben nicht mehr wenden das
müsste man sich natürlich finanziert
aber es gibt auch argumente gegen das
koma kommt jedoch die man auch über die
anderen sprechen aber dann die
finanzierung ist schon ein punkt und ich
würde schon frau hamann unterstützen
wenn man sich das anschaut und dann sagt
1000 euro für jeden im monat das ist in
deutschland ein betrag von 1000
milliarden euro wenn wir jetzt unsere
anschauen der bundeshaushalt hat
ungefähr 350 milliarden
die gesamten steuereinnahmen in
deutschland sind ungefähr bei 700
milliarden und wir sprechen jetzt bei
über 1000 über 1000 mit einer afg
programmatik und popularisierung also
recht zu kommen doch keines transfer die
seiten institut sie müssen wir
kalkulieren müssen wir sozialstaat
funktioniert sowieso kein sozialstaat
aufgebaut wie tausend mal 8 82
milliarden mal zwölf zu recht immer so
rechnet doch kein mensch
die rechten
ein gutachter soll daraus gebühren
geld das du da müsste sind also sie
finanzierbar das ganze doch mal wenig
dann sagen wir es doch dass die für sie
finanzieren eben über die können wir das
steuer bei sie das grundeinkommen das
heißt althaus vorgeschlagen sie können
ein grund da kommt als
sozialversicherung sowie ist die
schweizer in der rentenversicherung
machen als eine bürger
sozialversicherung können sie auch
machen sie können ein nischenmodell
machen wird die rentenversicherung wo
die redebeiträge haben uns hohe
bundeszuschüsse aus dem haushalt der
wiederum sind auch über indirekte
steuern können ganz unterschiedlich
strukturen legen geht auch ihr modell
einfach mal vor wenn die sagen ich
möchte kein modell
ein gedanke der nach dem andern jetzt
warum sind sie gegen das grundkonzept
wenn sie wollen dass die menschen weiter
abhängig sind wenn sie nicht wollen dass
sie unabhängige sind dann nicht beraten
mehr geld zur verfügung haben die
arbeiten als menschen die nicht arbeiten
ist auf dem grundsatz von unserer
gewählt wo man sagen ja dann möchte ich
daran festhalten das wichtig ja
destiny schon wir wissen auch es gibt
eine große unterstützung von
leistungsgerechtigkeit und es gibt auch
eine große unterstützung dafür zu sagen
dass diejenigen die arbeiten gehen die
auch sie jeden morgen aufstehen die auch
was dafür tun denen es auch unangenehm
ist dass die dadurch ein höheres
einkommen haben als menschen die nicht
ein
die nicht arbeiten gehen natürlich ist
aber auch kein argument das ich möchte
dass die menschen in der abhängigkeit
bleiben ich möchte einfach wir haben
ganz bestimmte soziale probleme ganz
natürlich also hat für ein soziales
problem arbeitslosigkeit ein problem
integration von immigranten ist ein
soziales problem wir haben viele
probleme zum beispiel in der
schulpolitik
ich möchte dass diese probleme
bearbeitet werden ich möchte auch dass
der staat viel geld dafür in die hand
nimmt und ich glaube das ist ein
richtiger weg ich glaube dieses freiheit
versprechen dass die befürworter des
grundeinkommens nach
haben das ist ein falsches versprechen
nämlich mit 500 euro im monat sind sie
nicht frei 4000 euro im monat sind sie
auch nicht frei sie sind frei wenn sie
entscheiden können was möchte ich mit
meinem leben machen wenn sie eine gute
qualifikation haben etwas sehr schönes
gesagt beim letzten wochen gesagt anders
als sie die leute sich mühe gegeben
die sollen die für die interessieren wir
uns weiß was dran
wer sich mühe gibt aber wohin das mühe
geben genau besteht ob es daran besteht
ob sie jetzt ihr kinder als ihn ob sie
sich personen pflege durch sorgen ob sie
genau in erwerbsarbeit drin sind das
sind fragen die im einzelfall sehr genau
anschauen muss ihrem lebenszyklus
anschauen da sind wir gar nicht so weit
auseinander glauben aber würden sie denn
sagen das ist eigentlich eine
eigentlichen grundeinkommen de facto in
deutschland gibt weil durch hartz iv und
wohngeld als gedacht dass man eigentlich
an klar ist eine eigene version wir
haben die tendenz dazu ihnen aber wir
haben eine unklare tendenz die
bevölkerung wird verwirrt durch die
jetzigen regelungen und es bleibt ein
diskriminierungs element für hartz4
empfänger was signifikant ist wird ihren
biss mit arbeitsmarktpolitik auskennt
und vor allem mit den menschen mit
mehrfachen vermittlungshemmnissen der
weiß wie sehr auch genau diese leute
darunter leiden stigmatisiert zu werden
eben als nicht weniger
und das ist ein problem und da sehe ich
das problem für das problem dass
sozusagen menschen und zwar immer wieder
umfang
gerade menschen die besonderen schützen
notwendig hätten dass die unter diesem
aktivierungs ideologie leiden und die
idee für sie rechts wie links die finger
spd die finden sie dazu sich jetzt und
administration
da geht sie ganz hoch und ich bin sonst
ein vertreter einer menschenrechtlichen
und sozialpolitik und das war dabei
unter den usa arbeitet ist auch hier
dass man schon dann nochmal euro im
burgenland aber was würden sie denn
sagen dass die leute wenn es um rund
ankommen gebe
das ist keine motivation mehr gebe dann
zwischen job zu suchen und zu arbeiten
doch ist gelbe eine motivation ist dass
ich den leuten gar nicht absprechen
das sieht arbeiten würden
aber man muss sich eben klar machen aber
ich will jetzt die ganzen berechnungs
debatten nicht wieder auf kochen aber
man muss sich klar machen dass bei den
gängigen modellen grundeinkommens der
op-art ein leicht anderes modell sie
sich jetzt raus hat aber bei den
gängigen modellen wurden am ende alle
mehr haben und es um klagen da
finanziert sein soll
und jetzt nochmal locator konkret zu
werden
ich stimme ihm völlig zu dass es ein
ganz großes problem ist dass sie hartz 4
empfänger ersten zu wenig geld bekommen
und zweitens stigmatisiert werden und
dass diese ganze aktivierungs ideologie
nach dem motto fördern und fordern immer
so tut als wären die alle irgendwie
nicht ganz ernst zu nehmen also wie wir
darin erwachsene wie kinder behandelt
dass für mich alles ein enormes problem
das muss man auch angehen aber ich
glaube eben dass man das anders machen
muss als so nah gießkannenprinzip namens
grundeinkommen sondern dass man ganz
konkret sagt ok hat hier wird
aufgestockt die arbeitsagenturen werden
tatsächlich kundenorientierter es gibt
sich diese im ganzen kontrolle waren
das würde tatsächlich das lösen und dass
ich jetzt noch gerne sagen würde als
letztes ist aus meiner sicht ist weil im
zugleich sein okay kann jetzt nicht aber
bei sehr vielen grundeinkommens
befürwortern ist aus meiner sicht der
focus falsch wenn ich in der form dass
es immer um diese erwerbsfähigen geht
nun und eigentlich nicht um die rentner
wir haben aber ein problem bei den
rentnern denn da würde das da gibt's ja
gerade neue studien dass sehr viele
rentner hat künftig in altersarmut sein
werden das heißt dass man eigentlich
braucht ist ein grundeinkommen für
rentner also nur grundsicherung wie weit
höher ist als heute würde er lernt man
dann ist für die erwerbsfähigen braucht
weil nämlich der demografische wandel
dazu führen wird dass facharbeiter und
akademiker eigentlich alle die irgendwie
arbeiten kennen können wenn händeringend
gebraucht nur ein beispiel auch aus
dieser woche bayern hat nicht mehr genug
lehrer die dürfen jetzt noch nicht mal
mehr in teilzeit gehen das heißt da
sieht man schon dass der fahrer weiter
mangel indirekt da ist und man wird also
sich um die erziehung kümmern müssen die
werden alle dort haben die auch gut sind
und wie man dabei handy warum wollen wir
denn dann trotzdem den leuten die
arbeiten können und die gesucht werden
warum sollen sie dann trotzdem irgendwie
so eine basis kriegen was ich meine
diese arbeitsbegriff ist einfach cool
gehört dass das wird einfach recht hier
noch in berlin zusammen setzen sagen es
gibt welche die arbeiten
es gibt welches nicht arbeiten alle
menschen arbeiten nicht nur die die
erwerbsarbeit haben was ist dann mit der
arbeit zu hause wenn man die kinder
aufzieht die schöne dass es eine der
wichtigsten arbeiten und eine
investition in die schule kommen wir zum
kern des auch die frau lag ist etwas
sehr gut wie wird man faul war wird man
wenn man etwas tun muss wurde man keinen
sinn sieht kann jede beobachten weiß ich
selber wenn man sich mit etwas nicht
identifizieren kann eigentlich das gegen
die moral die arbeit voran geht das aber
machen muss dann weigert man sich da
wird man faul aber das ist eben
eigentlich für gesund und in diesem
sinne ist die musiker kommen einer
initiative gegen die faulheit weil
nachher wenn es das gibt kann gar
niemand mehr etwas was wir tun will mich
machen und was bedeutet es wenn menschen
die einfach die toiletten sauber machen
die auf dem schlachthof arbeiten für
wenig geld gibt es nicht mehr
ja du hast operationalisieren werden
oder müssen als anständig werkstätten
ich jedenfalls möchte nicht in einer
gesellschaft leben in der drecksarbeit
gemacht werden weil menschen aus der
küste ist das annimmt ich möchte die
menschen richtig wertschätzen und zwar
alle mit erwerbsarbeit leisten aber
bleiben dann nicht aber es bleibt wenn
ich die drecksarbeit liegen vor
doch und da wird für deine mal
interessant wenn man sich fragt wie
wirkt ein grundeinkommen auf löhne zum
beispiel und die befürworter des
grundeinkommens sagen ja immer ja dann
kann man sich aussuchen und man hat ja
ein grundeinkommen und man kann sich
dann sozusagen besser entscheiden mache
ich jetzt noch diesen schlecht bezahlten
job im schlachthof oder oder woanders
aber die frage ist ja wirklich ob der
arbeitsmarkt funktioniert ich glaube zum
beispiel dass er nicht so funktionieren
würde sondern der arbeitsmarkt so
funktionieren dass der arbeitgeber der
auch in einen schlechten job anbietet
dem arbeit suchen dann sagt sie oh du
hast deine 1000 euro grundeinkommen wenn
du mehr haben möchte mache ich das gerne
und ich zeige dir drei euro in der
stunde dafür und dann derjenige der ich
war ja noch gar nicht fertig die
existenz
wenn die existenz ist
auf dem fahrrad um ausreden die 1000
euro ist die existenz nicht gesichert
eur 200 mio eur auf einem armutsniveau
und wenn sie dann sagen ich möchte aber
gerne aus meiner armut situation
rauskommen ich möchte einen job ich habe
aber keine guten qualifikation wofür
mehr an arbeitgeber auch viel geld
bezahlen würde sondern ich habe geringe
qualifikation und ich bin in einem
bestimmten arbeitsmarkt segment dann
würde kein arbeitgeber dieser welt sagen
ja ich zahle dir die zehn euro die
stunde 20 euro die stunde 30 euro die
stunde von denen sie ausgehen sondern
die arbeitgeber würde sagen du hast ja
schon sein einkommen ich geb dir ein
bisschen was dazu wenn du diese
schlechte arbeit macht ich finde die
sowas von unwürdig ich wusste seit
jahren solche diskussion sitzen
professor und gut bezahlte redakteure
die weit entfernt sind von grund
einkommensniveau und reden abstrakt über
die leute die im grundeinkommens bereich
leben schauen sich die leute konkret an
schauen sie die untersuchung an dieser
zugibt und zwar nicht abstrakte tarif
untersuchen sondern lebensweltlich
orientiert und suchen wie geht es den
menschen
wir werden sie verschiedenes dabei
feststellen dass zum beispiel die die
grundschüler die grundsicherung für
kinder enorm hilfreich war und ist weil
sie personen
der grund sie diese zuschläge die die
sagen ohne moduliert hinein
hartz-iv-bezug fallen jetzt nicht hartz
iv-bezug hineinkommen
das heißt in die unteren einkommen fit
nennt machen 10 15 20 prozent einkommen
sehr viel aus sehr viel erscheint ihnen
vielleicht lächerlich wie man mit trauer
aber die frage ob dann auch die arbeit
gemacht wird
die frage ist heute gehen sie in die
welt und schaut immer dorthin wo die
wirklich schlecht bezahlten unwürdige
arbeitsverhältnisse stattfinden in
deutschland gibt es die auch aber nicht
in großem maßstab
dort wo die menschen keine alternative
existenzsicherung gehen sie dort also
schauen sie in der großen teil der räte
über sein werk la paz ein altenpfleger
was heißt das für die altenpflege heißt
es zum beispiel
natürlich sind vollkommen einig sie
brauchen gewerkschaft
der organisation die frauen tarifbindung
die brauche ich hatte mich so auf ihn
richtige sache ich persönlich bin sehr
dafür ein mindestlohn ein guter muslim
aber häufig aus weil in der tat wie es
gibt natürlich arbeitgeber interessen
die individuelle zu drücken die
absichtlich aber umgekehrt ist sollte
man die arbeitnehmer die adoption arbeit
verkaufen müssen auch nicht für dumm
verkaufen sind sehr wohl in der lage
wenn die rahmenbedingungen stimmen
also wenn sozusagen gesamtlänge ändern
und eben nicht nur einfach das konto
wird kommen hilft extrem viel weißem
leuten die option gibt ein tragischer
ist es sinnvoll in der gesellschaft
weiterhin eben einkommen so extremen
arbeit zukommen wird auch leute
wir haben ja auch schon von rd die erben
was wir haben also die haben ihr geld
gut angelegt und die arbeiten auch nicht
aber ihr geld arbeitet und dem geht's
ganz gut dabei das finden wir dann auch
in ordnung also gleich eine andere sagen
wir mal einfacher weil man also
natürlich ist die ungleichheit in der
gesellschaft die ungleichheit der
einkommen und zu einigen auf dass die
ungleichheit bei den vermögen ist
tatsächlich ein problem so jetzt ist die
frage wie geht man das an und was man
einfach sehen muss ist es gab noch nie
weltweit irgendwo ein grundeinkommen und
wenn man das machen würde dass wir so
als würde man knoll in die gesellschaft
halten und alles um umstürzen und um
ändern
und da ist meine antwort das ist einfach
ineffektiv erstens es wird
wahrscheinlich zu teuer zweitens ist es
nicht ausprobiert und wir haben super
methoden aus vergangenheit und denen wir
wissen dass sie funktionieren wenn man
die umverteilung verstärken will also
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel sagte das
ist doch unfair dass die erben da
eigentlich leistungslose einkommen
bezieht und dass sie nie gearbeitet
haben da weiß man was wir die saison
wäre wenn ich eine hohe absatz steuer
eine vermögenssteuer die man dann
genauso investieren so die frau hatte
das gesagt hat nämlich in bildung in
pflege und so weiter oder man sagt
mindestlohn für pflegekräfte damit sie
nicht ausgebeutet werden man macht
tarifverträge für geschäfte die haben
wir nicht
okay da muss ich einfach sagen wir
hoffen immer sie würden die praxis
kennen und wir hätten keine ahnung und
wahrheit ist es umgekehrt es gibt einen
riesigen niedriglohnsektor zu ja genau
das potenzial haben
natürlich also offenbar bisher noch
nicht die tarifbindung die wir brauchen
und das könnte man ja nicht unterschied
versuchen sie auch ja eben aber das
können wir ja alles einführen
tarifbindung heraus als die bayern geht
er aufgrund einer zeit auch leben wo
sich eben viele arbeitslose die
arbeitswelt stark ändert wir merken dass
solche digitalisierung viele niedrig
qualifizierte jobs werden wegfallen
da braucht man keine menschen mehr für
das machen dann demnächst roboter ist
das so eine zeit wo man sagt ja wir
müssen einfach ganz anders auf arbeit
gucken ist das war das von prosieben
damit war eine triebfeder für ihre
initiative auf arbeit natürlich
digitalisierung industrie 4 0 da kann
man sagen dass da das klinikum nicht
mehr humanistische antwort auf den
technologischen fortschritt das ist eine
schiene ist aber nicht die wichtigste
sondern wir das richtig normal mit ihnen
diskutieren weiteren umfeld arbeiten um
verteilung so wichtig ist bedingungslose
grundeinkommen ich sah keinen grundsatz
ist keiner geld umverteilung des
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens einer
gemacht umverteilung die macht es dann
beim einzelnen und wenn sie dagegen sind
wenn sie gegen die macht unter tragen
sind
da können sie argumentieren gang dann
werden sie transparente war mit seinem
nachruhm vertrag aber das klingt pokal
und trotzdem kollege andersen der 1000er
das grundeinkommen wird und jemand der
im super gut bezahlten job hatte da ist
das machtgefälle doch da noch genauso
wie vorher auch ja aber wenn sie nicht
mehr über die existenzsicherung wird
zwinker sind zwar sind in etwas hinein
kränker sind dann haben sie eben einen
sehr mächtigen werden in weiten grenzen
in dieser diskussion habe ein buch in
deutschland vor habt ihr euch haben
volles werden deutschland ist ein tolles
land wirklich guten hier als würde
deutschland die mauer leben wenn man
sich schon arbeit deutschland lebe nicht
in deutschland wird den beschluss und
das sollten wir so wir erkennen ob die
grenzen daraus ein variables umverteilt
werden verhandeln sie da sie wie sagen
wie es würde es muss umverteilt werden
und warum ist dann das grundeinkommen
nicht auch ein instrument von der
sinnvollen umverteilung versieht also
ich bin auch für um verteile ich bin
aufgeregt oder von noch
sowohl als auch aber ich glaube nicht
dass das grundeinkommen die macht
umverteilt das grundeinkommen wer die
machtverhältnisse zementieren noch mehr
zementieren als jetzt schon
weil die vorstellung ist ja dass man
sagt man gibt 1000 euro für alle oder
von die auf 1500 euro für alle im monat
und damit hat man sein auskommen damit
kann man sich befreien von den zwängen
des merken marktes nun das ist ja der
grund einfach die die grundeinstellung
davon und führten den audi schickt ohne
bedingungen genau die existenz gesichert
aber man lebt natürlich nicht ein ein
auskömmliches leben sondern lebt in
armut leben man lebt ein leben an der
armutsgrenze und sobald man sobald man
von dieser armutsgrenze sich entfernen
möchte ist man dem markt noch stärker
ausgesetzt war noch störte warum noch
stärker so stehe ich nicht auf meinem
server angewiesen weil natürlich warum
warum warum attackieren die gelegenheit
weil sie also ich nämlich an dass sie
auch die wirtschaft damit abschaffen
wollen oder dass sie wirklich sagen wir
brauchen keine arbeitgeber keine
unternehmen mehr wir haben keinen
arbeitsmarkt mehr sondern wir haben
natürlich einen arbeitsmarkt und der
arbeitsmarkt ist immer noch so dass ein
arbeitgeber ihn so viel geld wie er
meint ihn gehen zu müssen
und er meint ihnen geben zu müssen wenn
sie ein auskommen schon haben ist der
zusatz er ihnen seine tat sind relativ
gering arbeitgeber markt aus der
arbeitsmarkt geht eigentlich in einem
tarifgebundenen sozialstaat mit
kooperativ zwischen struktur davon aus
dass arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer gibt
idealtypisch sozusagen über löhne
handeln und die gewerkschaften helfen
ihnen dabei das heißt die vorstellung
dass du doch ein grundeinkommen einen
touren arbeitgeber markt hätten dem die
arbeiten immer nichts mehr zu sagen
hätten modell
so stellt ihren tieren gewartet sind ja
auch viele unternehmer für dieses
grundeinkommen hier haben sie das gefühl
die sind deshalb dabei weil sie dann
arbeitet audi arbeiter er überrollt und
ausbildung zu dir vorstellen dass man
dann billigere jobs anbieten
die denn trotz über die jahre so die
gewerkschaften das problem sie haben
vielleicht die unternehmer tollhaus
naja es gibt ja viele unternehmer die
darüber nachdenken die sich genau mit
digitalisierung beschäftigen mit
umbrüchen name arbeitsmarkt beschäftigen
die schon voraussehen das ist
wahrscheinlich zu großen verlagerungen
kommen wird auch zur großen
rationalisierung kommen wir zur wegfall
von arbeitsplätzen und die dann
antizipieren er überlegen wie können wir
damit umgehen mit einer zeit von großer
unsicherheit und dann sagen ja wenn der
staat und sein grundeinkommen zur
verfügung stellen würde würden wir ein
großes smartphone unsicherheit und bei
martin arbeitgebern wegnehmen aber auch
natürlich der gesellschaft nehmen und
ich glaube daraus speist sich das
interesse am grundeinkommen es sind
oftmals auch unternehmen und arbeitgeber
die für ein grundeinkommen sind die auch
gleichzeitig sehr viel dafür tun dass
sie sehr wenig steuern bezahlen müssen
das geht ja sehr oft wenn sie sich vor
wenn man sagt man bilden verteilen dann
würde vielleicht auch unter dem oder
andere mehr steuern bezahlen aber auch
unternehmer haben kaffeehaus genau dafür
bin ich ja dafür war jetzt nochmals mit
dem arbeitsmarkt mit dem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen hätten wir nachher einen
freien arbeitsmarkt heißt an freiheit
wenn es was bedeutet dies ohne
tarifbindung noch weiter wollen moment
mal grundsätzlich damit kann ich mit den
alten methoden die die probleme lösen
und damit geschafft hat also manchmal
einfach denken aber angst frei denken
mit dem grundeinkommen hätten wir einen
freien arbeitsmarkt sei heißt man muss
nicht teilnehmen dann hätten wir einen
freien arbeitsmarkt der einzelne
arbeitnehmer werde nicht mehr erpressbar
ich weiß nicht warum viele aufgaben aus
gewerbeschein heimarbeit gemacht die
gemacht werden muss er trotzdem
wir möchten sie dass menschen zur arbeit
machen weil sie müssen ja ich bin schon
das wo das es lehrer gibt und polizisten
dass die arbeit die die wir brauchen das
die bereitete haufens jetzt echte spiele
und polizisten hier in diesem land dass
sie müssen aber ich sage es gibt schon
arbeit die getan werden muss die frage
ja nicht wirklich muss man muss eben
begeistern könne man muss den zehen
einen arbeit darstellen können so dass
menschen sagen ort da sehe ich den sinn
ein
da will ich nicht dass irgendwas mach
ich und das ist eigentlich noch klaffen
tun
die realistisch man arbeite daran ist
dass wir noch mal zurück ging zu dieser
idee mit der digitalisierung und das
dadurch dann alle jobs wegfallen
also und muss erstmal sehen dass das
sehr gut ist wenn die produktivität
steigt das bedeutet ja nichts anderes
als weniger menschen können das gleiche
herstellen wie das genau brauchen wir
weil wir eine gesellschaft sind die in
einer wahnsinnigen geschwindigkeit
altert und wir werden immer mehr
menschen versorgen müssen die gar nicht
arbeiten können und die tatsächlich ein
grundeinkommen brauchen und mindestrente
ich sage es gibt immer mehr alte leute
die nicht arbeiten können aber ein
verlust griffel hochrangiger ebene aber
die brauchen ein vernünftiges
grundeinkommen versuchen das muss
irgendwie erarbeitet werden und auch mal
ausreden ist sehr sehr nett und dieses
dieses einkommen kann ja erarbeitet
werden durch maschinen
das funktioniert aber eben nur wenn man
diese digitalisierung auch zunächst so
insofern ist die digitalisierung keine
gefahr sondern eine wenn sie denn
stattfindet eine wirkliche befreiung
europa zahlen keine steuern fällig wenn
sie waren herstellen die verkauft werden
können dann gibt es dennoch ein
einkommen und man besteuert nicht die
roboter dann würde man ja diesen
produktivitätsfortschritt händen sondern
wird man die steuer dann diejenigen die
gewinne damit machen dass sie die
roboter einsetzen
das ist ja bisher auch nicht anders also
tut immer so als wir die digitalisierung
wirklich was völlig neues aber in
wahrheit ist es ja so dass seit dem
bestehen des kapitalismus der jetzt
ungefähr 250 jahre alt wird ja ständig
neue technik eingesetzt es gibt auch
ständig diese produktivitätsfortschritte
sie sind wirklich gut so und jetzt
kommen wir noch mal zu dem thema
was ist mit der arbeit die trotzdem
übrig bleibt das sind wir denn die
polizisten das sind die lehrer dass die
pflegekräfte da ist nichts von
digitalisierung zu sehen wobei schon
gewollt schon sagen dass viele leute
gibt die diesen job gerne machen ja
genau gemacht werden die werden
wahrscheinlich nicht digitalisiert
werden alles was mit menschen zu tun hat
lässt sich eigentlich nicht
rationalisieren
diese arbeiten muss gemacht werden und
da ist aus meiner sicht eben wichtig
tatsächlich dass die löhne gut sind dass
sie hoch sind dass man mindestlöhne hat
wenn noch mal zu dieser zu dem problem
das geht ja hier ein bisschen
durcheinander kann man finanzieren das
hat man eigentlich hinterher was nicht
ich glaube dass so ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen pro person hätte eine
ganz seltsame konsequenz nämlich wenn
man allein stehend ist wäre man am genau
wie frau hatte das duo schreib man hätte
1000 euro und das würde nicht reichen
wenn man aber eine vierköpfige familie
wäre dann geben ein reicher als 95%
heute denn man hat der 48.000 netto im
jahr
und das ist irgendwie in den komplex
teilung slogan die den kindern wenig
anpassen kann
dazu stand in seriösen verstand
einführen wollen es irgendwie möglich
ist und der gesunde menschenverstand
würde dann auch vielleicht brauchen die
kinder erst ein niedriges gründer kommt
je nach dem in der ausbildung brauchen
sie vielleicht ein höheres überhaupt der
gesunden menschenverstand ist kann ich
sie geschlagen allermeisten empfehlen
wenn man über so eine große idee wie das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen leute
mitgenommen und beschuldigungen in ein
deckel reinspringen mit dem kopf und
dann dann sieht man es gar nicht nur
einfach mal diese idee jeder mensch hat
das recht zu existieren hier in unserer
gesellschaft ohne dass an seiner
existenz eine bedingung gestellt wird
die menschheit sie die es geht auch
nicht von heute auf morgen gekommen was
würde sich verändern
diese gesellschaft aussehen das wieder
ändern ich habe eine zukunftsstudie
altenhilfe in drei jahren in schleswig
holstein und interessant ist sozusagen
leute sich mit der langfristigen zukunft
beschäftigen und fast alle gruppen
hindurch wir haben eine tiefe affinität
zum grundeinkommens haben wir gar nicht
eingebracht ihr habt sondern haben sie
warum sie das haben weil sie spüren das
ist in der tat so eine mischung aus
kultur idee das müssen wir als
wissenschaftler versuchen den nachzug
nachzulaufen zu schauen was ist im 21
jahrhundert die richtige form der
existenzsicherung und natürlich wird der
arbeitsplatz ein ganz zentraler punkt
sein natürlich werden wir
unterschiedliche einkommen zu haben
aber während auch mehr gleichheit
brauchen und jetzige idee dass unser
jetziges system wirklich
leistungsgerecht ist es kann doch kein
ernstzunehmender wissenschaftler
journalisten sagen keiner
wir haben eine enorme spreizung wir
haben einkommensarten sind völlig
unangemessen und sie haben im unteren
einkommensbereich menschen die nicht
richtig wissen wie sie die runden kommen
soll
und da ist und ein kombiniert hat auch
eine gewisse umverteilung auch nicht so
gerne hört ein modell ab aber ich glaube
dass die dass die dass wir natürlich
einkommensgruppen die ich denke was die
beiden da die beiden kolleginnen hier
angesprochen haben sind stimmig in
weiten teilen zu ich bin in der tat der
auffassung dass wir stärker auf mehr
gleichheit setzen müssen dass die
meisten leute wollen das auch aber
gleich heißt aber nicht gekoppelt an
diese erwerbsarbeit doktrin aber da
könnten anlagen oder sonst eine
erbschaftssteuer
ich glaube in den kapitalismus im 21
jahrhundert müssen die leute ermächtigen
die da jeder bürger jede bürgerin
braucht lebenslang die idee dass er nein
sagen können das beherzigen ja nur durch
1000 euro d also ich glaub das ist
wirklich der große unterschied weil die
allmächtigen menschen indem sie ihnen
eine gute qualifikation geben in dem die
schulbildung gmbh für mich nein aber
irgendwas sagen sie doch auch nicht
mächtigen menschen indem wir ihnen ein
gutes kurs vorgeben und das ist bildung
und das ist auch eine bestimmte
natürliche absicherung um natürliches
soziale sicherung nur wenn ich eine
große reform mache
und wenn ich menschen ermächtigen möchte
dann gebe ich ihnen ein handwerkszeug
und das handwerkszeug sind nicht tausend
euro weil sie sagen also man muss
kapitaleinkünfte besteuern
vermögenssteuer erbschaftssteuer und hat
vier anheben
also dann er hat man ja eine
umverteilung der mittel warum sagen sie
dann aber trotzdem bei hartz4 zb ich
will diese ganze bürokratie ich will
dass jeder sich genau erklären muss
warum er das alles mal warum wären da
nicht noch die bauern halle nicht wenn
man es umverteilt okay dann dann sollen
sie halt eben auch alle bedürftigen
kriegen bedingungslos naja bei
bedürftigen bedingungslos haben zu der
dann schon widerspruch dran wenn sie
sagen alle bedürftigen da muss der
bedürftige zeigen dass er die lustige
oder alle da sein keine erwerbsarbeit
fehler in der arbeit ein aber dennoch
haben wir die bedingungen also ich hab
ja gar nichts dagegen wenn man kann die
sanktionen abmildern man kann sich ja
alles möglich überlegen wie man jetzt
die ganzen bürokratischen hürden bei uns
bei hartz4 verändert erleichtert und
weiter da mich überhaupt nichts dagegen
nur bedingungslos heißt man kann schaut
dann gar nicht mehr hin lassen sie mich
auch aus welchem grund kommen was wir
alle schon haben die zukunft
bedingungslos wird und jetzt in
deutschland sehr dringend nötig weiter
haben wir ein sozial staatliches system
hat vier sind das ist ein skandal
das ist eine schande für deutschland
eine schande für europa ist sogar
zweites thema mich mit dass in
deutschland ein solches sozialsystem ist
weil hier das existenzminimum ist
funktioniert
wer ist denn da hin ich glaube
deutschland hat ein herzproblem einem
dachschaden oder herrn schlug aber die
antwort ist im grunde kommt ist ein
schritt in die richtige in der zweiten
aber 77 prozent der menschen bei dem
referenten gesamten kultur aktiv in die
spitze bist du nicht aufhören der
kompass in deutschland haben wir schon
umfrage mit 53 prozent sind für das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen aus dem
wahlkampf ist das symbol das thema
doping thema das noch sagen wenn sie
wollen
die wahren gewinner müssen sie für
bundesweite volksabstimmungen sein das
haben sie in der bevölkerung über 70
prozent die das haben wir müssen
diskutieren und elena kommt man aber die
spd und die linken und die tierwelt
hermann was denken sie wie realisierung
da irgendwie in der realität die
einführung von grundeinkommen deutsche
setzen ließ ein soll man merkt schon
dass langsam ein thema gibt in schleswig
holstein soll zum modellversuch geben
modellversuch orientiert sich dann mehr
oder minder an finnland und da muss man
sich einfach mal klarmachen was
empfinden stimmt was okay aber finnland
wurde ja hier auch als modell gepriesen
und da muss man einfach klar haben was
finnland gemacht hat war ein sparmodell
da wurden 2000 arbeitslose letztlich mit
560 euro abgespeist und die idee war
dass man bei der arbeitsverwaltung spart
auf kosten arbeit wurden das hat man
dann aber nicht grundeinkommen genannt
und seitdem wird das hier also ein
modell gefeiert und ich glaube wenn den
deutschen klar wird dass das aber so
ungefähr das modell wäre das beim
grundeinkommen rauskäme während wie
dagegen also ich glaube dass letztlich
immer wenn es um politik geht die leute
dann doch auf bewährte konzept zu setzen
und das ist eben hartz4 hoch dafür bin
ich ja durchaus umverteilung durch
einkommensteuer und so weiter aber nicht
die gießkanne okay wenn nur noch die
letzte minute haben deshalb die frage
einfach an alle in die runde was würde
sich dann in ihrem leben ändern herauf
jäger wenn sie 1000 euro grundeinkommen
ich werde was meine tochter meine enkel
betrifft ruhig so manche studenten
besucht beruhigte ich mir geht es um die
zukunft nicht nur um die gegenwart
okay man hier bei mir würde sich ändern
dass ich wüsste alle anderen sind gar
nicht mehr bis geld erpressbar
öffentlichen riesengewinn auch ich
spreche aus unternehmen für die
wirtschaft für die kultur
mit weniger lohn mal weniger lohn einer
erkältung eine idee die menschen in
kraft zu bringen dass sie etwas leisten
können aber selbst bestimmt und das geht
allerdings auf den grund ging nicht um
mehr ohne leim machen ein bisschen mehr
steuern bewegt wenn sie 1000 euro etwa
ich wollte immer noch sondern listen
bleiben ok frau hat aber die finden das
ändern
das bedauern weil ich mir überlegen
würde was man mit dem geld alles machen
könnte und ich würde es wirklich schaden
finden dass wir dieses geld nicht
benutzen um wirklich soziale probleme in
unserem land anzupassen
okay gut also ich eine menge argumente
sind ausgetauscht pro und contra bleibt
hier auf beiden seiten glaube ich hat
sich nicht gegenseitig überzeugt für
gespannt wie wie finden morgen sind wir
wieder für sie da in der phoenix runde
dann reden wir über die ehe für alle
knick die union ein ich hoffe wäre das
wieder biss dann
[Musik]